directrice générale mon général la
commission des lois et la commission de
la culture vous entendent aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de leur mission conjointe
de contrôle sur le signalement et le
traitement des pressions menaces et
agressions dont les assignants peuvent
être victimes si cette mission
d'information ne peut se pencher sur le
fait qu'il font l'objet d'une enquête en
cours
l'assassinti son objectif est de
s'intéresser au aux modalités de de
prévention d'évaluation et de traitement
des menaces exercé à l'encontre des
enseignant et au-delà de l'ensemble des
membres de la communauté éducative notre
premier axe d'interrogation porte sur
les modalité de dépôt des plaintes et
des mains courantes de la part des
enseignants victimes d'agression ainsi
bien sûr que leur traitement en
particulier disposez-vous d'éléments
relatifs au délis moyen de de traitement
de ces plaintes comment les agents
concernés sont-ils informés de leur
stade d'avancement en deuxème lieu nous
souhaitons serion avoir des précisions
quant aux suites policières qui sont
données à ces plaintes dans quelle
mesure les plaintes donnent-elles lieu à
des arrestations en outre dans quel cas
l'agent enseignant ou administratif
menacé peut-il bénéficier d'une mesure
de protection policière une autre forme
de pression que subissent les
enseignants retient également
l'attention de de nos travaux celle qui
celle que constitu les plaintes
dépensées à l'encontre des enseignants
notamment par les parents d'élèves
dispos vous sur ce sujet d'éléments
précis et statistiques enfin nous
serions intéressés par toute précision
que vous pourriez apporter concernant
les partenariats qui existent entre les
préfectures les services de police et de
gendarmerie les parquets et les
rectorats comment les services de police
et de gendarmerie et le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale coordonnent-ils
leur action pour agir contre les menaces
et agressions à l'encontre des
enseignants
madame monsieur je vous rappelle que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat nos travaux ayant par
ailleurs obtenu du Sénat l'obtention des
prérogatives des des commissions
d'enquête je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage serait passible des peines
prévu aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal et je vais vous inviter
Madame et Monsieur à prêter serement de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le
jure général merci j'aurais dû commencer
par là mais j'excuse le président buffet
qui
est qui a été contraint de de se rendre
à une autre réunion et qui passera
reviendra peut-être dès lors que sa
réunion sera terminée sans plus tarder
je vais vous laisser la la parole pour
un propos liminaire et puis après je ne
doute pas que mes collègues présents
auront des questions à vous
poser
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
mesdames et
messieurs un propos général
d'introduction monsieur le Président qui
essaiera d'évoquer un certain nombre des
des points que vous avez évoqué je
précise que je suis accompagné de
Virginie Bruner qui est la directrice
nationale de la sécurité publique et qui
a ce titre à responsabilité aujourd'hui
sur la totalité des des commissariats de
police hors compéten territorial de la
préfecture de police et que précédemment
elle exerçait des fonctions
territoriales dans un grand département
confronté à des phénomènes de cette de
de cette nature et qu'elle pourra à ce
titre évidemment compléter mon propos
par des données concrètes un propos très
général pour vous indiquer que les
missions de la police nationale qui
conduisent évidemment à engager des
mesures de prévention d'identification
des auteurs d'infraction euh de
poursuite des enquêtes judiciaires auin
de présenter les auteurs devant la
justice conduisent évidemment sur
plusieurs de ces de ces métiers à
interagir de manière dense avec le
milieu enseignant et plus globalement la
la comm communauté éducative et que de
ce fait il existe et je commence par
votre question de la fin mais il existe
de ce fait un partenariat très dense et
très ancien euh faisant intervenir la
police nationale
euh dans le lien avec l'éducation
nationale partenariat qui s'est
évidemment renforcé au fil du temps au
fil des années au fil des des crises et
au fil des drames pour faire face et
prendre en compte de la manière la plus
adaptée possible les enjeux de sécurité
rencontré dans le milieu et dans le
cadre éducatif plusieurs volets
traduisent ce ce ce
partenariat un premier grand volet qui
est un volet de
prévention qui qui conduit à à
l'instauration d'une relation suivie et
de confiance et qui s'exprime dans le
cadre d'une coordination vous l'avez
évoqué à l'échelle territoriale qu'elle
soit évidemment à l'échelle des
circonscriptions donc des établissement
ou à l'échelle départementale au niveau
des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale de mise en place
d'un système
pluridisciplinaire pour prendre en
compte les problématiques rencontrées
par le par la communauté enseignante la
communauté éducative et pouvoir y
apporter des des solution cela se fait
évidemment pour ce qui concerne la poli
la police nationale sous l'autorité du
représentant de l'État le préfet bien
évidemment le
rectorat avec plusieurs plusieurs axes
de travail souvent d'ailleurs une
convention partenariale est signée pour
permettre l'échange d'information très
très concret dans un certain nombre de
de situations un de nos premiers c'est
évidemment de pouvoir prendre en compte
la nature des risques et les menaces
auxquelles sont sont confrontés les les
établissements et nous travaillons dans
ce cadre làà avec l'autorité préfectoral
le rectorat et les services de
renseignement qui nous aident à
identifier la nature des menaces qui
peuvent peser sur sur les établissements
nous travaillons aussi en lien avec les
parquets qui sont évidemment
régulièrement sollicités pour nous
permettre d'avoir des moyens
d'action particulièrement par exemple
pour émettre des réquisitions qui nous
permettent des contrôles divers à
l'occasion et aux abords des
établissements scolaires qui nous
permettent de de répondre à des à des à
des préoccupations exprimées et aussi un
partenariat qui s'inscrit en lien très
fort avec les les municipalités qui
disposent évidemment des différents
pouvoirs qui leur permettent
d'intervenir et qui peuvent aussi
mobiliser leurs propres leurs propres
services la prévention elle se traduit
euh donc par la mise en place d'actions
nombreuses de prévention un échange
régulier des partenariats noués qui se
nou tant au niveau local que
départemental des correspondances
spécialisées et identifié euh qui sont
mis en œuvre dans la totalité des
circonscriptions de de sécurité publique
et qui permettent de désigner des
interlocuteurs privilégiés pour les
chefs d'établissement des rencontres
régulières des jalons établis pour des
contacts réguliers en dehors des crises
évidemment la préparation des rentrées
scolaires sont autant d'occasion de
faire un point sur les perspectives pour
l'établissement la nature des
difficultés rencontrées un point
d'ensemble et également de mobiliser des
mesures de prévention situationnelle
grâce à un réseau de référents sûreté
qui sont présents dans la totalité des
des services placés sous la
responsabilité de de Madame Bruner et
qui permettent de conseiller les chefs
d'établissement par des mesures
concrètes de sécurisation passive des
des établissements d'aménagement on y
associe bien souvent d'ailleurs les
services municipaux pour pouvoir
intervenir sur des enjeux d'urbanisme
extérieur ce volet de prévention il nous
permet le développement d'un d'un réseau
de proximité dense intense qui rend
d'autant plus facile l'action
opérationnelle quand elle est
malheureusement nécessaire cette action
opérationnelle euh c'est un volet ancien
mais qui s'est évidemment renforcé là
aussi au regard des niveaux de menacees
à l'encontre des personnels et à
l'encontre de la communauté enseignante
vous avez évoqué l'affaire l'affaire
l'assassinat Patier évidemment nous
avons eu aussi à connaître l'attentat
d'aras qui nous a rappelé l'ampleur de
de cette menace tout ça se traduit par
un certain nombre de mesures spécifiques
qui visent à nous permettre de répondre
vite bien euh aux demandes euh de la
communauté éducative des chefs
d'établissement ou encore des
enseignants et l'actualité récente nous
le démontre puisque nous avons à couvrir
sur nos nos territoire aujourd'hui la
situation de Rennes qui est abondamment
reprise par la presse depuis le le
milieu de matinée un des premiers axes
c'est évidemment le traitement
prioritaires des appels au secours donc
des appels police secours qui
parviennent sur le 17 qui doivent nous
permettre d'intervenir le plus vite
possible quand un appel survient madame
Bruner dispose d'information le cas
échéant si vous souhaitez sur les délis
d'intervention à aras comme à Rennes
aujourd'hui qui témoigne de la
réactivité des services quand un appel
survient évidemment un déplacement
systématique des équipages avec une
logique de ne pas sousqualifier un appel
quand il parvient qui peut ne pas être
très précis quand un appel police
secours survient sur un centre
d'information et de commandement il peut
être un peu brouillon il peut être un
peu imprécis parce que l'information
n'est pas toujours stabilisée l'enjeu
c'est que les les effectifs prennent en
compte à chaque fois avec le même le
même sérieux et la même diligence les
appels qui qui parviennent une
coordination renforcée qui nous permet
aussi de préparer les modalités
d'intervention dans les établissements
scolaires euh un un établissement
scolaire n'est pas un établissement
comme un autre euh on y trouve des
enfants on y trouve des enseignants
l'objectif est de pouvoir intervenir
évidemment vite et bien dans le cadre de
la menace terroriste qui a connu notre
pays ces dernières années euh nombre de
plans de de euh d'exercices ont été
menés euh dans les établissements tout
cela se fait à chaque fois en concours
avec bien souvent les polices
municipales euh évidemment les services
de police nationales et tout ça nous a
conduit à mettre en place des modalités
d'intervention dans les établissements
on nous permet par exemple de disposer
des plans des établissements de manière
à pouvoir intervenir en cas de crise et
de disposer pour les services Primot
intervenants comme pour les services
d'intervention les unités spécialisées
d'intervention des moyens des moyens
d'intervenir après le temps de
l'intervention vient aussi l'enjeu ou en
même temps ou en parallèle selon la
gravité des faits du sujet de la prise
de plainte vous l'avez vous l'avez
évoqué la prise de plainte est
déterminante en ce qu'elle ouvre un
champ judiciaire qui rend possible un
levier d'action plus large et nous nous
sommes engagés dans une démarche
maintenant depuis plusieurs années un
d'accompagnement qualitative de cette
prise de plainte avec l'enjeu de
faciliter la prise de plainte euh pour
les personnels victimes d'infraction
d'être en mesure euh de de d'assumer une
forme de prise en compte personnalisée
avec des logiques par exemple de prise
de rendez-vous euh des logiques aussi
que nous pouvons rendre possible parfois
de de délocalisation de la de la prise
de plainte nous sommes en mesure de le
faire parfois dans certaines situations
et aussi de mobiliser tous les services
de soutien l'accompagnement des des
victimes le soutien des associations de
victimes qui peuvent être nécessaires
pour les euh pour les pour les
enseignants face au fait dont ils sont
victimes
euh nous essayons aussi également
d'associer au maximum la communauté
éducative dans tout le travail
partenarial que nous menons de manière
très concrète sur des problématique
identifié à l'échelon territorial et je
voulais citer ici l'initiative
développée par la sécurité publique des
groupements partenariats opérationnels
des partenariats opérationnels les GPO
pour ceux d'entre vous qui qui ont à
connaître peut-être de ces dispositifs
sur sur leur circonscription ce sont des
des réunions pluridisciplinaires autour
de problématiques concrè on l'a pas
voulu comme une comitologie non
productive mais une réunion de concrète
sur des problètiques concrètes bien
identifié de tous les acteurs ayant
vocation à pouvoir conduire une action
sur une problématique et nombre d'entre
elles peuvent avoir lieu r tour des
établissements scolaires ça peut être
des squat aux abord d'établissement
scolaires ça peut être des
problématiques de circulation ça peut
être des problématiques de flux sur les
établissement scolaire et tout ça peut
paraître en en comment dire en en
périphérie du sujet de la sécurité de la
communauté éducative mais par la force
des choses les chefs d'établissements
sont préoccupés aussi par tout ce qui se
passe devant leurs établissements parce
qu'ils ont la responsabilité des des des
enfants qui fréquentent leurs
établissements et nous intervenons avec
eux sur ces sujetsl euh ce que je
voulais aussi vous vous indiquer qui est
c'est que la densification et
l'intensification de de du partenariat
des modalités de prise en compte de
notre réaction aux phénomènes dont sont
victimes les enseignants vise aussi à
répondre à une logique de réalité du
phénomène qui augmente et qui augmente
dans plusieurs configurations nous vous
fournirons dans le cadre du
questionnaire les statistiques émises
par le service statistique ministériel
du la sécurité intérieure qui établit
donc le le le périmètre statistique mais
qui met en exerg des phénomènes d' mtion
des violences physiques mais également
des atteintes à la dignité et à la
personnalité au préjudice de la
communauté enseignante sur les trois
dernières années on observe que l'année
2021 a été une année de pic très
importante je pense que ça correspond
aussi aux suitees de l'assassinat de
Samuel pti avec des phénomènes
probablement plus nombreux en réaction
et des plaintes également ou des
signalements plus
nombreux l'année 2022 a été un peu moins
importante que 2021 mais se met quand
même dans une dynamique de progression
par rapport à 2020 donc c'est un
phénomène qui s'installe et qu'il nous
faut évidemment prendre prendre en
compte euh également ce phénomène il est
de plus en plus protéiforme parce que
nous avons tous fréquenté des
établissements scolaires et on les
enseignants pouvaient aussi être victime
de violence ou d'insulte on observe une
dimension nouvelle qu'il nous faut
prendre en compte et que les deux
l'assassinat de Samuel pati a mis en
exerg c'est toute la dimension numérique
ou virtuelle des menaces euh qui est
évidemment cette dimension virtuelle des
réseaux sociaux qui est ur de
propagation d'information qui est un
facteur de diffusion de fausses
informations et qui est aussi un facteur
de diffusion et d'expression de menac
menac visant des personnalités
individuelles mais menaces visant aussi
des établissements et nous avons eu à
connaître depuis notamment l'attentat
d'aras une multiplication des phénomènes
de menaces parvenu par voie virtuelle au
préjudice des établissements et d'alerte
à la bombe qui ont généré vous le savez
un nombre conséquent d'évacuation
d'établissement euh et ce sont
évidemment ces menaces avec cette
dimension virtuelle des faits qui
peuvent aboutir au pire comme cela c'est
c'est produit dans la situation que vous
avez évoqué je voulais à cet égard
souligner la mobilisation de
Faros que vous connaissez probablement
de nom qui est la plateforme
d'harmonisation d'analyse et de
recoupement et d'orientation des
signalements qui est animé par la
Direction Nationale de la police Judici
mais qui est un un outil qui vise à
accueillir des des des personnels de
police et de gendarmerie qui a vocation
à nous permettre de mieux détecter et
judiciariser les violences et les
menaces dans l'espace numérique et à cet
égard Faros exploite les signalements
relatif au contenu licide qui sont
diffusés en ligne et qui alors qui
porent évidemment sur certains
phénomènes autres mais qui notamment
porte beaucoup d'enjeux de menace et
d'apologie du terrorisme nous conduisons
sur la base du recroupement des
signalement et sur leur analyse deux
types d'action deux dimensions d'action
avec une dimension administrative qui
vise à permettre la suppression ou le
déréférencement des contenus illicites
qui sont identifiés et c'est important
pour nous parce qu'un contenu retiré
c'est un contenu qui se diffuse moins et
qui du coup nous peut nous laisser
espérer qu' produira moins de dégâts en
terme de viralité ou de ou de reprise ou
d'influence sur des public fragile et
évidemment une action à dimension
judiciaire puisque cette logique nous
permet de procéder à l'identification
des auteurs des infractions et à
rechercher la les preuves et bien
évidemment euh conduire les intéressés
devant la justice euh et nous avons un
nombre de nombre de faits dans dans
cette situation et je voulais je voulais
vous confirmer que sans revenir sur les
les les phénomènes postérieur à
l'assassinat de Samuel pati nous avons
connu euh un une augmentation des
phénomènes après euh l'attentat commis
au lycée Gambetta d'arace avec de nombre
de de signalements euh qu' nous a fallu
traiter mais aussi des des
interpellations que nous avons pu
réaliser
ce phénomène- là nous conduit euh à ne
pas négliger la dimension dangereuse que
peut prendre une menace
euh et à appréhender euh l'évaluation
des menaces nous mobilisons pour cela
sur des situations bien singulières
l'unité de concours à la lutte
antiterroriste que vous connaissez sous
l'acronyme ulat qui est une unité qui
dépend de la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieur et qui procède à
l'évaluation des menaces euh qui peut
poser sur des ces personnalités c'est
sur cette base de l'évaluation des
menaces que nous pouvons être conduits à
mettre en œuvre des mesures de
protection euh ces mesures de protection
elles prennent deux grands formats il
existe des mesures de protection
rapprochées mais qui ne sont pas des
mesures mises au bénéfice de de tout le
monde pour des questions de de moyens
d'abord vous savez que ce sont les
mesures de protection qu'on met en place
au bénéfice notamment de de de
personnalité ou de membres du
gouvernement euh et mais nous sommes
parfois conduits euh à à le faire au
bénéfice de de d'enseignant
et à cet égard je voulais vous indiquer
que luclat a été conduite en 2021 à
procéd à une évaluation sur trois
personnels de l'Éducation nationale
après des des dépôts de plaines et que
une personne a été protégée par le
service de la protection le SDLP qui a
la charge de ces missions et en 2022 5
personnes ayant déposé plinte issu de la
communauté éducative ont fait l'objet
d'une évaluation mais ces évaluations
n'ont pas u à ce que des mesures de
protection rapprochées soient mis en
œuvre une protection rapprochée non mise
en œuvre ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
mette pas en place de mesures de
protection qui seront alors plutôt des
mesures de protection territoriale qui
passent par des logiques de patrouille
plus régulières aux abords des
établissements scolaires par des points
fixes qui peuvent être réalisés aux
heures sensibles qui peuvent être les
heures d'arrivée et de départ d'un
personnel menacé nous sommes en mesure
de mettre en œuvre les mêmes mesures de
vigilance aussi aux abords euh du du
domicile ce sont d'ailleurs des mesures
que nous déclinons souvent avec nos
camarades de la gendarmerie nationale
quand un enseignant exerce en zone de
compétence police nationale mais réside
en zone de compétence gendarmerie
nationale et inversement et nous faisons
aussi en sorte de pouvoir intégrer les
coordonnées
personnelles des des des personnes ayant
manifesté des inquiétudes dans nos
centres d'information et de commandement
de manière à ce que quand nous recevons
les appels de ces personnes en cas
d'urgence leur numéos puissent être
immédiatment identifiés et que ça nous
permette de déterminer tout de suite le
niveau de la menace et d'engager
d'autant plus d'autant plus vite les
moyens les moyens
d'intervenir nous serons en mesure
évidemment de de développer si vous le
souhaitez l'ensemble des des des des
mesures de manière concrète vous
précisez aussi ce que nous avons été
conduits à redurcir après l'attentat
d'aras dans le cadre du Plan vigip
pirate urgence attentat mise en œuvre
après l'attentat de de au préjudice de
Dominique Bernard ça a été l'occasion
évidemment de reconduire des réunions
dans avec les les établissements scol
de refaire un point sur leurs attentes
particulières d'y répondre aussi et puis
d'être d'être en mesure de de décliner
des dispositifs spécifiques de réactiver
je dirais entre guillemets des
dispositifs spécifiques qui étaient
existants qui sont bien identifié que
Madame Bruner avait rappelé en d'autres
circonstances avant même l'attentat pour
rappeler que la communauté éducative est
un point est un point de vigilance nous
avions aussi dans le cadre du conflit
israél-palestinien émis à nouveau des
des des points de vigilance sur la
communauté éducative au regard de la
cible que ça pouvait constituer tout ça
pour pour s'inscrire dans dans la
logique une fois encore d'accompagnement
qualitatif que nous souhaitons
développer au bénéfice de la communauté
éducative voilà monsieur le Président ce
que je voulais vous dire en propos très
général le plus complet possible merci
Madame la Directrice en
général monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de de compléter sans redite le
propos de Madame Berton puisque tout ce
qu'elle a évoqué se décline logiquement
pour la gendarmerie nationale peut-être
faire un petit rappel historique sur
cette problématique de sécurité de
l'espace scolaire qui a émergé
finalement il y a presque une trentaine
d'années he puisque les premiers
dispositifs ont été mis en place dans
les années 96 et c'était un peu une un
premier pas si je dire qui rapprochait
les forces de sécurité du monde
éducatif et donc tourné à l'époque de
manière assez générale sur la sécuration
de l'espace scolaire mais avec une
focalisation peut-être sur les
stupéfiants l'usage des stupéfiants qui
était déjà un sujet au sein
desétablissement et assez axé aussi sur
la la connaissance mutuelle et la
prévention ça a permis progressivement
un rapprochement avec le monde éducatif
he dont il faut avouer que tout départ
on était relativement éloigné les
préoccupations de sécurité n'entend pas
et naturellement au cœur de leur de leur
préoccupation on a une pour nous une
étape importante si en 2009 où ces
sujets de de violence dans établissement
scolaire autour des établissement
scolaires ont été on va pris une
dimension beaucoup plus marquée et plus
générale c'était plus seulement un sujet
du stupéfiant il y avait voilà déjà des
violences contre les enseignants et des
violences autour et des établissements
scolaires donc à cette époque- làà on a
créé nous un référence scolaire dans
chaque brigade de gendarmerie et ce
dispositif existe évidemment toujours et
la mission comme l'a rappelé Céline à
propos des des des circonscriptions de
sécurité publique c'est un contact avec
l'ensemble des établissements qui sont
implantés sur la circonscription de la
brigade et d'être le le point d'entrée
parfaitement identifié des enseignants
et principalement des chefs
d'établissement avec avec lequel ils
sont ils doivent entretenir des
relations régulières des visites de
l'établissement et également être son
conseiller si j'ose dire en cas de de
difficultés et l'orienter ensuite vers
les référents de prévention technique de
la malveillance s'il y a des diagnostics
et cetera à
faire l'étape suivante c'est évidemment
la période des attentats terroristes
2015-26 où on s'est beaucoup penché sur
la sécurisation de l'espace scolaire en
lui-même c'est empêcher une action une
tuie de masse dans un établissement
scolaire donc là on c'est plutôt euh
orienté sur la sécurisation passive
d'établissement le réhaussement des
contrôles d'accès et cetera et donc on
appuie là encore des communautés
éducatives et puis aussi des
collectivités territoriales responsables
des travaux de ces établissements
scolaires donc c'était assez accès il y
a beaucoup d'exercices aussi hein et
donc tout un travail je dirais de
protocolisation avec les les chefs
d'établissement sur comment on confine
les élèves et comment nous on intervient
dans ce cadre-là euh et gérer l'étape
suivante dramatique et ce qui qui marque
une évolution c'est euh évidemment
l'assassinat de Samuel Patti où on sort
à la fois de l'espace scolaire puisque
la menace sur les enseignants n'est plus
circonscrite au au lycée au collège ou à
l'école et on a aussi une une une
évolution dans le sens où on a on a
vraiment deux thématiques on a la
violence contre les les enseignants lié
à des comportements
individuels voilà d'élèves ou de ou
d'environnement problématique mais on a
une dimension
idéologique lié au séparatisme qui est
un sujet je pense qui est un peu au cœur
de de vos travaux et qui évidemment
vient dramatiquement être illustré par
le l'assassinat de Samuel Patti donc là
aujourd'hui on est dans une une
problématique un peu différente c'est
queon doit plus s'intéresser seulement à
l'établissement en lui-même sa
sécurisation le lien avec la communauté
éducative mais bien la capacité à
sécuriser à prendre en compte la la
sécurité d'un d'un enseignant y compris
en dans sa vie personnelle voilà donc
sinine a rappelé tous les dispositifs
qui sont en place et qui sont
aujourd'hui particulièrement évidemment
suiv avec une très grande vigilante pour
assurer la protection des enseignants
euh quelques éléments aussi peut-être de
pour donner un peu une dimension le
volume pour la gendarmerie c'est
27000800 23800 pardon écoles à peu près
56 % des écoles sont en zone gendarmerie
on a 7700 établissement du second ré ça
représenteès 43 % et on a 2144
établissements du super rieurs c'est à
peu près 19 % des établissements donc on
a un volume d'établissement extrêmement
important qu'on partage évidemment avec
la police nationale et évidemment le
nombre d'enseignants la communauté
éducative ce plus plus évidemment plus
d'un million d'enseignants et de membres
de la communauté donc c'est pas un sujet
qu'on peut comment dire assez facilement
circonscrire c'est bien un sujet qui
concerne toutes les unités et qui
concerne tout le monde alors ensuite sur
le
phénomène l'évolution de cette des
atteintes au au monde éducatif
est à la hausse clairement et je dirais
dans une tendance assez similaire à à
l'augmentation générale des violences
qu'on n pas pour nous on n pas de de
singularité ni en positif ni en
négatif des atteintes au aux
enseignants et d'une manière générale
atteintes au représentant de l'autorité
puisque je pense que il faut les mettre
dans l'ensemble des personnes qui
incarnent une autorité un titre
quelconque qui à ce titre là peuvent
être peuvent être
contestés les départements qui sont les
plus concernés
pour la gendarmerie c'est assez c'est
naturellement des départements à très
forte population pour nous c'est la
Gironde la Haute Garonne l'iser le Nord
l'Oise l'é et le P
decalé donc il y a pas une déterministme
territoriale très très claire on voit
que c'est quand même assez assez
réparti c'est intéressant de
s'intéresser un petit peu aussi au aux
auteurs et on a 45 % des auteurs qui
sont mineurs ce qui veut dire que 5 %
sont 55 % sont majeurs et donc à part
certains qui on peut-être un parcours
scolaire un peu
retardé n'appartiennent pas ne sont pas
des élèves en fait ça veut dire ce sont
des parents ce sont des trè riseurs ce
sont des tiers et donc c'est c'est c'est
VO intéressant de voir que finalement
une part importante des auteurs sont
extérieurs à l'établissement scolaire
non non et non pas normalement vocation
à y pénétrer bon sauf les parents quand
ils sont invités à des réunion mais
sinon et donc ça a aussi une incidence
sur la la la la parti partie réponse
pénale que vous avez souhaité
développer sur les infractions on est
quand même principalement je dirais
principalement sur des outrages des
menaces des menaces de mort des insultes
des injures la part des violences étant
heureusement très minoritaire mais pour
autant aujourd'hui quand on menace un
enseignant de mort c'est pas du tout ça
reste comment dire ça pèse sur sa c'est
c'est c'est c'est vraiment une épée
d'amoclesè parce queon sait très bien
que ça peut se traduire par un acte réel
donc ce faitl sont pas anecdotiqu euh on
est lucide à 40 % alors vous allez me
dire c'est pas beaucoup parce qu'on
pourrait imaginer qu'on on identifie les
auteurs alors pourquoi on CIDE à 40 %
parce qu'il y a un certain nombre de
faits qui sont des insultes des tags des
dégradations donc quand on crève les
pneus du véhicule de l'enseignant sur le
parking devant l'école quand on écrit
monsieur machin et ceci ou cela c'est là
pour le coup c'est très compliqué à
lucider enche quand on est sur les
atteintes physiques les violences
évidemment les auteurs sont beaucoup
plus simples à
identifier par rapport à ce phénomène le
texte de référence en matière de de
prise en compte c'est l'instruction de
2020 je la connais pas par cœur
retrouver la la
référence l'instruction
interministérielle de de 2000 du 27
octobre 2020 qui est relative à la
sécurisation de l'espace scolaire et aux
mesures d' accompagnement du
corpsenseignant c'est postérieur
évidemment à l'attentat qui a visé
Samuel Patti alors cette circulaire
l'instruction pardon elle met en place
un accompagnement des enseignants une
incitation forte au dépôt de plainte ce
qu'on peut observer c'est contrairement
à ce qu'on a mis en place pour la lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales il
y a pas de
systématisation aujourd'hui d'une
enquête judiciaire sur les vif
aujourd'hui qui est plainte ou pas
plainte à partir moment où l'enquêteur a
connaissance de faits de nature qui sont
susceptibl qualification question pénale
il doit ouvrir une enquête judiciaire et
en aviser le parquet c'est pas
aujourd'hui aussi net que ça sur la
partie des violences enfin des atteintes
aux enseignants alors ça s'explique
aussi parce qu'on a une partie
importante des auteurs qui sont des
mineurs donc il la partient aussi au
souvent à parquet de peut-être de
privilégier des traitement
administratifs he il y a tout le travail
disciplinaire et autres propres à
l'établissement et une enquête
judiciaire est pas forcément toujours
indispensable et même toujours opportune
mais il y a peut-être une marge de
réflexion sur le fait que il y ait pas
d'angle mort et que un enseignant qui va
signer les défets en disant non mais je
veux pas déposer plainte bon aujourd'hui
ça peut peut-être encore passer un peu
en dessous des écrans radar même si
normalement si les faits sont vraiment
d'une nature grave l'enquêteur doit
rendre compte au parquet il y a aussi un
comment un cordre de rappel puisque les
chefs d'établissement sont censés sont
réputés euh fait un article 40 de leur
côté pour tous les faits de nature
également de qui sont sucepti de
recevoir une qualification pénale bon il
s'agit pas d'emboliser le système
judiciaire avec des faits de nature
anecdotique évidemment mais si on veut
vraiment sécuriser les choses et
s'assurer qu'il y a pas de de rater dans
le dispositif je pense qu'il faut être
le plus précis possible dans les
dispositions qui sont qui sont mis mises
en
œuvre euh après sur les modalités de
dépôt de plainte de traitement euh il y
a une attention particulière évidemment
qui est apporté à ces faits puisqueil y
a un reporting systématique et national
donc toute atteinte à un enseignant un
membre de la communauté éducative fait
l'objet d'une remontée d'information au
niveau central et de remontée priorisée
donc la
hiérarchie comment dire des unités est
chargé de vérifier qu'à chaque fois les
choses sont prises sérieusement les
enquêtes sont enfin les plaintes sont
prises les investigations sont menées
sous l'autorité des magistrats les
délais de traitement ils sont variables
selon la complexité investigations si
vous avez l'auteur sous la main la
victime que les fait sont caractérisés
ils peuvent être extrêmement rapides
quand il s'agit de menace en ligne cequ
CG un signalement Faros ben ça peut
prendre des des semaines voire parfois
des mois pour identifier l'auteur quand
on y arrive quand il a il NAA pas été
for suffisamment prudent dans dans la
pour masquer ses son son origine donc
voilà je c'est sachez qu' enfin je pense
que il y a il y a toujours des toujours
avir des loupés mais globalement c'est
une vraie priorité pour tout le monde
qu'il s'agisse des des enquêteurs ou des
magistrats et donc les télés sont sont
sont le plus court possible de manière à
ce que la réponse soit la plus la plus
rapide
possible
euh voilà donc ensuite les mesures de
protection j''y reviens pas
puisque ces liges les a les a largement
développé ce qu'on peut aussi noter
c'est que le cadre juridique enfin notre
arsenal juridique est assez robuste hein
il y a évidemment toutes les les les
infractions aggravées liées à la qualité
d'enseignant euh il y a les mesures
judiciaires qui peuvent être prise
d'exclusion d'établissement scolairire
il y a aussi une infraction qui a été
créée par la loi séparatisme qui est
peut-être insuffisamment connu mais qui
répond quand même aussi au au au sujet
des des menaces qui qui défrait un peu
la chronique actuellement c'est
l'article
43331 du code pénal hein qui
est sur qui a trait à à la pression des
intimidations à l'égard de toutes
personne participant à l'exécution de
mission de service public afin d'obtenir
pour soi-même ou pour rutruit une
exemption totale ou partielle ou une
application différenciée des règles qui
régistent le fonctionnement du dis
service avec ça évidemment çariit à tout
ce qui concne les hôpitaux mais ça
s'applique je pense assez précisément un
certain nombre de situations qui sont
qui qui comment dire aujourd'hui visent
des établissements scolaires donc après
il faut peut-être sans doute mieux mieux
faire connaître et mieux déployer cet
outil juridique
peut-être pour avant de de conclure
étant préciser queon répondra de manière
très précise et détaillée aux questions
qui nous ont été adressées sur les
chiffres sur les différents
dispositifs peut-être un
carnet su fait imprimer l'ensemble des
faits qui qui ont qui ont émaillé
l'année 2023 peut-être incarner en
quelques un peu de manière totalement
aléatoire la nature de fait à quoi sont
confronté aujourd'hui nos enseignants
finalement vous allez voir que c'est
c'est c'est parfois extrêmement varié et
comment dire il y a toute une masse de
choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec cell
qui défrait la chronique médiatique
hein pendant un cours d'espagnol un
élève tire sur le professeur qui se
trouve au tableau à l'aide d'un pistolet
à haut le professeur demande à l'élève
de lui remettre le pistolet à haut
l'élève refuse à plusieurs reprises
avant de finir par le poser sur la table
professeur le confisque un deuxième
élève intervient et lui dit que le
pistolé lui appartient et qu'elle n'a
pas le droit de lui prendre les deux
jeunes filles continuent à réclamer
d'ordonner que la professeur le rend le
pistolet à haut et cetera euh donc donc
ça se termine par quand même des
intimidations à l'égard du professeur et
du
CPE l'auteur des fait se trouve en salle
de classe prend une photographie de sa
professeur alors qu'elle donne son cours
divulue la photo sur le réseau social
snapchat en l'écrivant grosse sur
l'image les élèves constatent la
publication on informe le professeur
celle-ci demande à l'auteur de lui
donner son téléphone professeur demande
à l'auteur de lui montrer le téléphone
l'élève refuse de le donner et refuse la
confiscation du téléphone le mise en
cause outrage sa professeur en cours
d'histoire géo lui disant qu'elle
l'emmer dans la traitant de pétass à la
fin du cours si tu c'est fait le mineur
fait l'objet d'une exclusion du collège
le soir même le mineur envoie unessage
sur le messagerie de à sa CPE disant
j'ai dit à Madame Intel qu'elle allait
mourir voilà le quotidien de nos
enseignants et on a comme ça 1000
combien 1250 à peu près bon c'est ça que
viv 1200 victimes c'est ça c'est il y a
15 on vous enverra les chiffres
consolidés je vrais pas vous dire de
bêtises bon voilà je vais pas égrainer
la totalité mais vous voyez qu'on est
dans c'est ce quotidien là que vivent
les enseignants et qu'il est et qu'il
est évidemment les déstabil alors et mon
sens de même que sur les violences
intrafiliales le message qu'on a fait
passer c'est la dépô de plein
systématique je crois qu'il faut aller
sur le même logique en matière
d'atteinte aux enseignants parce que
finalement c'est on a bien vu que sur
les viol famil au début toujours cette
logique de dire ouais relativiser un
petit peu finalement est-ce que ça sert
vraiment il y avait aussi une beaucoup
de de victimes qui se présentaient en
disant bon je veux pas déposer plainte
mais je vous signale que et puis on
s'est aperçu à l'usage que c'est pas
comme ça que ça fonctionne pour voir un
résultat efficace une véritable
répression et une exemplarité il faut
dépôt de plainte systématique et une
fois qu'il y a dépôt de plainte le
système se met en route il y a des
investigations et il y a il y aura des
décisions ensuite judiciires qui seront
prises voilà en quelques mots ce que je
voulais vous dire en en liminire merci
mon général Marie-Pierre
Monier merci président merci pour vos
propos et moi je voudrais revenir
sur les protections mises en place parce
que vous avez cité des cas madame qui
représente la police en particulier a
dit qu'il avait eu des dépôts de plein
parfois mais qui avait pas eu de de
protection rapproché ou pas mise en
place et je crois que monsieur le
Président Lafond avait une question
aussi sur ce sujet moi j'aimerais savoir
dans quel cas c'est c'est misise en
place parce qu'on a eu aussi des
exemples d'enseignants qui ont su des
menaces mais où ça pas été mis en place
donc j'ai bien compris qu'il fallait
déjà une plainte mais après quels sont
les critères les cas des fig que figure
où un enseignant peut faire l'objet
d'une protection de la part des forces
de
l'ordre ensuite à la suite de la mort de
Dominique Bernard il a été mise sur la
table la généralisation des boutons
d'alerte dans les écoles qui préviennent
immédiatement je suppose commissariat ou
gendarmerie je sais que ça existe déjà
dans des établissements scolaires est-ce
que vous avez des retours là-dessus sur
le fonctionnement de cet outil là où il
est déjà mis en place et de façon plus
générale quell serait vos préconisations
à vous concernant la sécurisation des
établissements scolaires vous avez parlé
de référents police et Monsieur aussi au
niveau de la gendarmerie a dit si j'ai
bien compris en fait c'est une
gendarmerie qui a tous les
établissements scolaires de son secteur
non alors j'aimerais savoir vraiment
comment c'est ce dispositif est mis en
place un petit peu plus précisément et
puis moi je suis rurale donc plutôt
d'une zone de
gendarmerie est-ce qu'il y a une
approche spécifique vous avez dit que
vous repreniez à votre à
votre tous les propos de votre collègue
qui est sur la zone de police mais
est-ce qu'il y a quand même des des
différences et puis nous avions fait une
mission avec deux collègues et établi un
rapport qui s'appelait bilan des mesures
des éducatives du quinkena nous l'avons
publié en juillet 23 donc ça c'était
après l'assassinat de Samuel pay et nous
étions de trois collègues dont max
prisson et Annique Billon et on avait
quand même reçu des enseignants qui
avaient le sentiment d'une moindre prise
en compte de leurs plainte par la police
com et la justice comparativement à
d'autres personnels dépositaires de
l'autorité publique ou chargé d'une
mission de service public est-ce qu'il y
a un une un travail de sensibilisation
parce que bon moi je m'occupe par
exemple beaucoup de violences faites aux
femmes je sais que c'est parfois dur
pour les femmes de porter plainte est-ce
que vous faites un travail dans vos
forces pour euh expliqué que c'est
important le le dépôt de PL auprès des
enseignants est-ce qu'elles sont
toujours enregistrées nous avons
auditionné une enseignante il y a peu
qui disait que elle elle n'avait pas été
prise sa plainte où est-ce qu'il y a des
pareil des critères très précis et
pareil vous en avez cité monsieur un
exemple de d'agissement verbal de
vis-à-vis est-ce que c'est pris en côte
aussi et de quelle façon
merci regrouper plusieurs questions si
vous le voulez bien comme ça çautêtre
répondre rapidement sur les sujets
spécifiques à la gendarmerie r euh alors
d'abord les références c'est un référent
par brigade territoriale et donc est en
charge de l'ensemble des établissements
scolaires implantés sur la circomprtion
de de la brigade ensuite pour j'ai pas
j'ai pas souhaiter peut-être
redévelopper dans le détail mais on a un
dispositif qui s'appelle sanctuisation
globale de l'espace scolaire he qui vise
à rassurer la communauté scolaire
travers l'action des fauteurs de trouble
et interpeller les auteurs pour les
traduire en justice c'est un DISP
général qui a été mis en place comme je
disais tout à l'heure en 2009 dans et
dont dont relève ces référents scolaires
on a également mis en
place un accès pour les enseignants à un
dispositif sécurisation des
interventions et protection c'est une
inscription dans notre base de données
de sécurité publique qui permet d'être
identifié et en cas de d'agression de
menace d'appel d'être priorisé et d'être
pris en compte immédiatement d'être
identifié par le le centre opérationnel
comme étant un enseignant et avec tous
les éléments d'identification le
domicile et cetera l'objectif étant
évidemment de pouir intervenir très
rapidement si une menace se caractérise
auprès de de l'enseignant et parmi les
des directives qui sont données c'est
que tout enseignant victime doit doit de
se voir proposer ce dispositif après on
peut pas l'imposer évidemment mais tout
enseignant qui souhaite rentrer dans ce
dispositif le peut et ça doit être lui
être systématiquement proposé au cas où
il soit victime et il se présente dans
une brigade de gendarmerie ce dispostif
permet aussi d'intégrer les domiciles
des enseignants concernés dans les
programmations de patrouille des unités
de manière à il passer régulièrement et
voilà rassurer puis si éventuellement
certains individus devaient roder aux
alentours pouvoir les détecter et et le
dissuader on a également des points
d'écoute gendarmerie dans certains
établissements c'est pas systématique et
dans les établissements les plus exposés
on a des gendes qui viennent
régulièrement au sein de l'établissement
alors ces points d'écoute ils ont été à
la base plutôt conçu pour les élèves
victimes de harcèlement scolaire c'est
plutôt pour justement faciliter la prise
en compte voilà pendant la récréation de
manière discrète il peut venir voir le
gendarme qui est là plutôt que de voir
se rendre à la brigade de gendarmerie
mais évidemment ça a aussi vocation à
servir aux enseignants c'est pas quelque
chose de totalement comment dire dédié
au au comment dire au aux élèves
victimes de harcèlement qui est aussi un
sujet d'actualité sur lequel on on
s'attache on s'attrache à travailler
peut-être aussi compléter en disant que
l'pice de protection il a une tion donc
il a les évaluations qui sont menées par
luclat pour les fait les plus graves
mais localement les autorités
préfectorales ont aussi la
possibilité de prescrire des mesures de
protection alors qu' seront pas du même
niveau hein que la protection au niveau
clat c'est une protection je dirais très
très lourde physique bon mais en
revanche le fait de avoir des passages
réguliers à proximité du domicile voire
du statique à certains moment si
vraiment il y a des faits qui sont des
menaces qui sont avéré voilà faire tout
le possible pour sécuriser et renforcer
forcer la protection des enseignants
concernés et évidemment des
établissements scolaires ou des faits
serait nature à se à se
passer voilà c'est ça fait aussi partie
des mesures qu'on doit être capable de
mettre en œuvre euh voilà je pense que
j'ai tout évoquer ce qui relève pour ce
qui relève spécifiquement de la la
gendarmerie s'agissant de dép de plainte
on n'est jamais à l'abri d'un loupé hein
avec avec 3000 points de vente et et
60000 gendarmes qui prennent des
plaintes on peut pas exclure qu'à un
moment il y a un raté mais honnêtement
le les consignes hiérarchiques très
précises et répété c'est que les les
plaintes doivent être pris
systématiquement et les cas qu'on évoque
ce sont des outrages c'est un délit donc
même si on est victime d'un insulte on
peut considérit que c'est banal non
parce que y aura une il y en aura deux
et puis toute une impunité qui s'instore
donc moi je reviens sur
mon de mon couloir c'est dépt de plainte
le plus systématique possible et et on
fera et notre notre rôle com on le fait
sur les violences intrafamiliales je
rappelle les violences intrafamiliales
pour G c'est 300 dépôts de plainte
quotidien euh c'est une déincance de
masse on se doit d'assurer un traitement
systématique de l'ensemble des plaintes
oui pour compléter effectivement je vais
commencer par le sujet de la plainte
puisque c'est c'est le sujet qu'évoquait
André petillot la position est la même
une un fait pénal déclaré c'est un dépôt
de plainte automatique là où il peut y
avoir discussion peut-être et en jeu
d'appréciation c'est quand on est sur
l'infrapénal et il peut y avoir
peut-être des enjeux d'accueil considéré
comme inapproprié sur des faits qui sont
mal qualifiés un peu confus mal
caractérisés par l'agent qui reçoit la
déclaration et ça peut peut-être parfois
donner lieu à une interprétation
inappropriée modulo l'erreur humaine
quiévoque André petillot qui évidemment
sur nos points de vente à nous euh
également euh conduire peut-être parfois
une une appréciation inappropriée mais
le principe est très clair et les
instructions sont très claires pour des
faits à dimension pénal qui sont portter
à notre connaissance pour l'éduc pour un
un personnel enseignant comme d'ailleurs
pour tout autre la logique et le dépôt
de plainte
euh l'enjeu après dans le suivi la prise
en compte le délai de traitement pourra
peut-être être un peu variable selon la
nature des faits on ne traitera
peut-être pas avec la même diligence une
insulte euh qu'un fait de violence ou
qu'un fait de menace selon aussi le le
le contexte des faits la personnalité de
l'auteur
euh l'ambiance sociale de
l'établissement tout ça sont des
éléments qui évidemment sont sont sont
pris en compte et et et qui nous faut
qu'il nous faut avec lesquel il nous
faut compenser mais bien souvent les
directeurs départementaux ou les chefs
de circonscription quand ils sont
confrontés à ces phénomènes incitent au
dépôt de plainte et parfois ils onti du
mal à convaincre sur le dépôt de plainte
euh il y a des faits récents qui ont été
évoqués dans la presse qui ont été
largement couverts par la presse sur
lesquels nous n'avons pas de dépôt de
plainte donc nous avons évidemment un
enjeu de mobilisation de nos moyens mais
il est là aussi très utile d'intervenir
dans cette logique un peu d'approche
pluridisciplinaire parce que c'est ce
qui fera bien souvent le gage de notre
efficacité c'est les mesures
disciplinaires prises dans
l'établissement et évidemment en
complément l'action étatique qui peut
être décliné notamment par le biais de
de de de de
plinte et c'est aussi important d'avoir
des référents qui du coup soi en mesure
de conseiller je rejoins à ce qui
indiquait tout à l'heure André petio
l'intérêt d'avoir un correspondant bien
identifié et je laisserai peut-être
madame Bruner vous dire deux mots de
détail parce que c'est intéressant c'est
c'est c'est de pouvoir conseiller aussi
sur la meilleure accroche la meilleure
approche la meilleure manière de de
conduire la la la réponse la
protection elle se fait une fois encore
effectivement de deux manières il y a ce
qu'on appelle la protection rapprochée
et ça ce sont donc des agents qui qui
sont H24 au contact d'une personne donc
vous imaginez que c'est un dispositif
exorbitant du droit commun qui est
évidemment très coûteux en en effectif
et qui ne peut pas être décliné en
n'importe quelle situation et qui
vocation du coup à s'appliquer quand une
menace c'est avéré et donc le travail de
luclat donc c'estité de concours à la
lutte antiterroriste qui dépend de la
DGSI et c'est pas neutre que ça dépend
de la DGSI c'est justement de mobiliser
ces outils ces capteurs sur lesquels je
ne peux pas m'étaler parce que je ne
dispose pas de de ces éléments et je
pense qu'ils sont ils sont ils sont
protégés euh visent à évidemment
caractériser la dimension avéré d'une
menace et quand cette menace est avérée
ça peut d'ailleurs par exemple tenir à
la personnalité de quelqu'un qui a émis
une menace sur sur un enseignant ça peut
conduire à la mise en œuvre de cette
mesure totalement exceptionnelle et
exorbitante de protection rapproché
quand on n'est pas dans cette situation
là pour autant on est en mesure de
décliner tout un tas d'autres
dispositifs qui qui vise à justement
prendre en compte une
inquiétude émise par un personnel
enseignant et qui conduis à à être en
mesure de décliner des choses quand même
assez individualisées et nous l'avons
fait en nombre en nombre de
circonstances dernier point avant de
proposer de laisser la parole à à Madame
Brunard vous avez écé le sujet du bouton
d'alerte le bouton d'alerte ça
supposerait que il y a un raccordement
direct entre un établissement scolaire
et un commissariat ou une gendarmerie et
que au déclenchement on intervienne par
habitude on sait vous le savez que un
bouton d'alarme il se déclenche parfois
de manière appropriée et à d'autres
moments de manière
inappropriée je ne pense pas qu'il
soit qu'il soit facile nécessairement de
passer par ce dispositif nous on a une
une traduction qui qui répond à cet
objectif nous avons dans nos centres
d'information et de commandement un
dispositif qui s'appelle l'alarme Ramses
qui est un dispositif qui permet
euh d'identifier des cor corresondant
entre guillemets privilégié et quand on
reçoit un appel sur ce dispositif Ramses
madame burner pourra aussi peut-être le
le décliner si vous le voulez parce
qu'elle connaît le dispositif ça nous
permet de prendre en compte une alarme
et de réagir c'est typiquement par ce
biais de ce dispositif qu'on prend en
compte les alertes émanant des
téléphones grave danger quand un
téléphone grave danger émet un appel si
je me trompe pas j'espère que je ne me
trompe pas c'est par ce B de dispositif
qu'on reçoit les alertes et qu'on est en
mesure de le de le traiter ça suppose
une forme de raccordement on a des
abonnés au dispositif Ramses qui sont du
coup des des services raccordés et que
nous sommes en mesure de de prendre en
compte donc c'est une modalité de
déclinaison que nous proposons pour ce
bouton d'alarme qui n'est pas
strictement parl un bouton d'alarme mais
une logique de DISP de dispositif et de
raccordement sur ce dispositif Ramses si
vous le voulez bien monsieur le
Président je laisse peut-être juste
développer Virginie Bruner C ces deux
bien sûr je don la parole à M Bruner
mais juste lui demander avant de prêter
serment comme on est en commission
d'enquête en levant la en disant toute
la vérité rien la vérité en levant la
main droite en disant je le jure j merci
Madame donc je vais vous parler des
correspondants spécifiques qui ont été
mis en place ils sont de plusieurs
niveaux le principal on appelle on
l'appelle le correspondant police
sécurité c'est l'échelon local vraiment
celui qui est le référent du chef
d'établissement donc de tous les
établissements scolaires sur le ressort
d'une circonscription vous avez au
niveau despartemental ce que l'on
appelle
le le le référent départemental police
éducation nationale lui a un enjeu plus
général et travaille sur l'ensemble du
département et vous en avez un 3è qui
est le chef de circonscription qui lui
va avoir également un rôle avec les
équipes de direction voilà du monde
enseignant voire même un 4e qui va être
ce qu'on appelle traditionnellement le
DDSP donc celui qui va avoir en fait
l'échelon départemental et lui va plutôt
travailler avec la dazen euh ou avec
avec le rectorat voilà selon les selon
les les secteurs sur lequels il se donc
on en a quatre deux très opérationnels
le correspondant police sécurité qui est
vraiment celui en prise directe avec les
chefs d'établissement le référent
départemental éducation nationale et
ensuite qui concerne plus les chefs de
servicees qui là ça va être le chef de
circonscription et le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
vraiment quatre types de référents après
on va en avoir d'autres sur certaines
thématiques spécifiques vous allez avoir
ce qu'on appelle lesé en sûreté pour
tout ce qui est audit de sûreté
puisqu'on a mis en place cette
culture de la sûreté en tout cas on
essaie de de de développer cette culture
de la de la sûreté au sein des
établissements scolaires et on a mis à
disposition des établissements scolaires
nos référents sûreté donc qui sont
chargés de faire
l'analyse bâtimentaire de la menace
extérieure et de de fournir en fait des
clés de lecture au chef d'établissement
et de leur de faire des audits
bâtimentaires sécuritaires pour leur
permettre en fait d'améliorer la
sécurisation de leurs
établissements et ils sont accompagnés
de ce qu'on appelle des correspondants
sûreté qui sont en fait l'échelon local
qui permett de de décliner également au
niveau local on a également ça on
partage c'est ce qu'on appelle les pfad
c'est les policiers formateurs
antidrogue qui étai initialement les
correspondants pour tout ce qui était
lutte contre le trafic de produits
stupéfiants voilà pour les grands schéma
sur les correspondants que l'on peut
avoir sur dispositif Ramses dont vous
venez de parler Madame la Directrice
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner si
vous l'avez pas là en tout cas nous
transmettre ultérieurement le nombre
d'établissements
qui aucun actuellement il y en a pas qui
sont qui sont qui sont raccrochés alors
fa encore c'est un dispositif de gestion
des alarmes agressions qui arrive donc
c'est en fait c'est un réseau
d'abonnés avec des alarmes qui se
déclenchent qui arrivent sur les
dispositifs de cent formation et de
commandement qui prennent en compte
l'alarme et qui du coup envoie envoie
une une patrouille ça suppose un
raccordement euh donc il a il y a un
coût d'installation et après il y a un
coût d'abonnement euh j'ai pas la les
éléments techniques mais ce sont des
choses qu'on pourrait évidemment vous
vous fornir euh voilà mais en l'étaat il
n à ma connaissance pas d'établissement
abonnés à ce dispositif encore c'est
c'est la police qui le propose ou c'est
le l'établissement qui en fait la
demande jusqu'à présent c'est pas un
dispositif qu'on proposait aux
établissement scolair d'accord il pas eu
propos jusqu c'est un dispositif qui
était existant pour des pour des des oui
plutôt des bâtiments publics avec bah
typiquement des
bâtiments
de la Banque de France enfin tout un tas
de choses de cette nature qui
répondaient à à cette logique qui
nécessitait des mesures de protection ou
de réaction particulière en cas
d'agression d'accord je comprends je don
la parole on va prendre regrouper les
questions si vous voulez bien bien
Jean-Michel Arnaud colombe Rossel oui
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames messieurs
de un témoignage et et une question le
témoignage vous l'avez dit vous-même il
peut y avoir des des des situations qui
vous échappent qui passe à travers les
mailles du filet j'entends je je porter
témoignage sachant que j'étais dans
cette commission un enseignant
professeur d'histoire de mon département
dans un lycée m'a adressé le message
suivant je dans ton et cetera au mois de
juin j'ai déposé une plainte contre un
de mes élèves qui avait posté une photo
de moi au cours en cours sur un réseau
social pas bien méchant certes mais le
même s'est révélé harceleur de camarad
conseiller de discipline etve exclu
définitivement et menace envers des
parents me rendant responsable de son
exclusion replainre contre les propos
des parents trois points de suspension
et puis plus rien jamais une nouvelle de
mes plaintes tris points de
suspension au-delà de ce témoignage ma
question j'ai j'ai l'impression qu'on
est en fait dans dans une zone grise
dans laquelle vous avez décrit
parfaitement je vous en remercie votre
capacité à vous
organiser moi j'ai le sentiment que et
vous l'aveiez vousmême dit certains
d'entre vous dans vos propos qu'on peut
avoir du disciplinaire donc des réponses
de caractère administratif interne avec
des mineurs conseill de discipline
exclusion on peut avoir un impact
extérieur avec des parents qui menacent
sur les réseaux sociaux qui menace
physiquement un enseignant visiblement
celui-ci qui dépose une plainte au mois
de juin de cette année qui n'a pas eu de
suite donc j'essaie de comprendre vous
avez des référents l'établissement
éducation nationale à des référents qui
normalement accompagnent l'enseignant
mise en danger ou qui se sent en danger
première question vous avez dit on
apprécie les situations comment on
objective l'appréciation des situations
votre perception en tant que force de
police extérieur l'établissement la
direction de l'établissement qui n'est
pas forcément dans la classe puisque
c'est bien la difficulté l'enseignant il
est face à une classe il y a lui et la
classe et les élèves donc donc comment
on apprécie les situations pour que vous
considérez que celle-ci ou une autre ne
mérite pas effectivement une attention
particulière une contue du contexte vous
l'avez même
dit le profil sociologique de
l'établissement des retours d'expérience
déjà antérieur et cetera qui font
alerter qui qui vous qui qui actionnent
une alerte spécifique comment être sûr
avec le dispositif que vous avez mis en
place que on ne passe pas à côté d'une
situation parce que toutes les
situations difficiles dans laquell nous
nous sommes trouvés parmi les plus
dramatiques chacun en lisant la presse
mais je me méfie toujours de lire trop
la presse sur ces sujets mais vous
avezvous connaissance du dossier le le
le juge connaissance du il y a une
instruction on voit très bien que c'est
souvent ce genre de situation o vous
êtes passé à côté ou quelqu'un est passé
à côté et on a un drame donc comment
vous appréciez quel est le critère
d'appréciation avec la communauté
éducative notamment les cadres en
responsabilité principale
proviseur qui vous permet de travailler
ce sujetl ma question complémentaire je
vais être bref il me semble que dans
tout ce que j'ai entendu il y a un
acteur que vous n'avez pas cité et qui
me paraît essentiel la collectivité
locale
euh on le voit sur tous les
sujets lorsque on a des situations
d'emprise dans le cadre scolaire
d'emprise dans le cadre familial ou de
violence faite aux femmes de mouvement
de développement de comportement
séparatiste dans les clubs de sport et
cetera on met la collectivité locale le
sujet puisque le réseau de proximité
c'est la collectivité locale or il
s'avère dans les établissements
1er degré 2 et 3e degré ce sont les
communes les départements et les régions
qui ont la main finalement sur les vis
sur les la
visiurveillance sur la sécurisation des
entrées sur des portiques sur le lien
avec la police de proximité en
complémentaire complémentaire à la votre
qui est la police municipale avec des
références sécurité parfois même dans
les conseils municipaux et vous n'avez
eu aucun mot sur sur sur cette relation
où je l'ai mal entendu et vous allez
préc
est-ce que vous pourriez n expliquer
comment cette architecture globale se
met en mouvement pour pour limiter au
maximum le
risque Colomb
brussell merci beaucoup à à tous les
deux pour vos présentation j'ai j'ai
deux questions qui me sont venues en en
vous écoutant de précision d'ailleurs la
première madame Berton vous disiez qu'il
y avait un certain nombre de conventions
qui avaient été signées avec des
rectorats est-ce que ça signifie que il
n il y a pas de convention signée avec
l'ensemble des rectorats pour les deux
zones police et gendarmerie est-ce que
c'est encore un chemin qu'il faut
accompagner pour que ces conventions
soient systématiques ou est-ce que en
fait ça existe partout mais du coup dans
dans vos propos je enfin en vous
écoutant je me suis interrogée et puis
une deuxième question je je vous
entendait et et l'un et l'autre
d'ailleurs mais peut-être plus monsieur
ptillot dire que euh l'un des points de
difficulté sur le dépôt de plainte était
souvent d'arriver à convaincre de
l'utilité du dépôt de plainte ce n'est
pas le seul secteur dans lequel ce sujet
existe est-ce que les services de police
ou de gendarmerie dans un travail de de
prévention sont sollicités ou proactifs
pour aller parler aux futurs enseignants
parce que ces futurs enseignants ils
sont tous à dans un même lieu dans un
même endroit au même moment lorsqu'ils
sont en cours de formation est-ce que
les sujets de sécurité globalement je je
crois que la réponse est oui mais de
sécurité des enseignants là j'avoue que
je ne sais pas est-ce que ce sont des
sujets qui sont abordés dans dans le
cadre de la formation et est-ce que vous
êtes sollicité ou proactif pour aller à
la rencontre des futurs enseignants
alors avant que vous ne répondiez à ces
deux questions je vais en rajouter une
troisè nous n'avons pas parlé des
fichiers s on sait qu'il y a des élèves
qui sont son fichiers et bien sûr qu'il
y a des parents dont les enfants sont
scolarisés dans les écoles est-ce qu'il
y a des procédures spécifiques
quand il y a un élève fichers S ou un
parent dont les enfants sont scolarisés
le parent éant fichers
s je laisserai cine peut-être développer
ce dernier point puisque c'est un sujet
qui est
traité en majorité par les services de
renseignement qui relève plus
directement de la DGPN même si bien sûr
on y est totalement
associé peut-être sur les convention
donc nous on a une convention nationale
avec la l'éducation nationale qui arrive
d'ailleurs à échéance donc on est en
train de la retravailler et donc
évidemment on va y intégrer un certain
nombre de de compléments au vu de
l'évolution de la menace qui frappe la
communaité éducative la prochaine étant
2024 2027 je parle sur votre contrôle et
ensuite décliner dans les territoires au
niveau départemental principalement sous
l'autorité des préfets euh concernant
les la formation euh il me semble pas
qu'on intervienne nous dans la formation
comment dire de base formation initiale
des enseignants et je pense que ce
serait effectivement quelque chose
d'intéressant alors à formaliser mais
qu' ait alors que ce soit police
gendarmerie magistrat enfin une une
incitation quelqu'un qui explique en
quoi il est important de déposer plainte
et là-dessus je reviens ce que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
faut aller c'est un à mon avis un un axe
de progrès c'est aller au-delà du dépôt
de plainte c'est-à-dire que codeénal
permet d'investiguer même s'il y a pas
de dépôt de plainte
c'est ce qu'on a fait sur les violences
extra familiales jusqu'à il y a encore
quelques années il y a pas de plainte on
dit bon ben si la dame veut pas déposer
plainte pas si grave que ça et on
passait autre chose aujourd'hui plainte
ou pas plainte égale enquête donc là
c'est un c'est un alors après derrière
faut pas que l'enquête soit
contre-productif parce qu'on est quand
même dans une environnement particulier
dans le monde éducatif pas le fait que
déclencher l'enquête judiciaire Vienne
finalement créer une situation ensuite
compliqué pour réinsérer un jeune qui
serait aait juste commis une erreur
temporaire mais ça pour nous l'idée dit
c'est au magistrat de l'évaluer et je
revient à la question de savoir le suivi
en fait la question c'est est-ce qu'il y
a une qualification pénale
oui non s'il y a un doute l'enquêteur il
doit poser la question au parquet si
s'il est pas sûr il doit poser la
question au parquet c'est au magistrat
de déterminer si oui ou non il considère
qu'il une infraction pénale s'il y a pas
d'infraction pénale il y a pas d'enquête
après il faut faut l'indiquer à la
personne c'est pas qu'on a pas envie de
travailler qu'on n a rien à faire de son
problème c'est qu'il y a pas
d'infraction pénale s'il y a une
infraction pénale après c'est au parquet
de comment comment dire de qualifier les
faits et ensuite de voir en liaison avec
la communauté éducative est-ce que
quelles sont les mesures administratives
qui ont été prise par l'établissement
est-ce que à ce titre là il y a lieu de
développer parilleur une enquête
judiciaire c'est exactement la même
chose que quand on a chez nous un
militaire ou un policier qui est qui
commet une faute qui a à la fois une
qualification disciplinaire et
potentiellement une qualification pénale
mais un échange avec le parquet pour
dire bon si vous lui avez mis une
sanction disciplinaire lourde on
considère que qui a pas lieu de faire
une enquête judiciaire en plus pour
avoir une réponse pénale qui de toute
façon ne rechangerait pas grand chose à
la chose donc c'est ça qui est important
c'est qu'il y ait pas d'angle mort en
fait hein et donc si tout le monde fait
son travail normalement ce genre de
situation ne devrait pas se se comment
dire se présenter après il faut que les
avis à victimes soient bien faits que
effectivement les les victimes soient
bien informé des suites qui sont données
à leur dossier et ça c'est c'est prévu
par les textes euh sur les collectivités
locales
elles sont évidemment concernées puisque
c'est elles qui ont la responsabilité
des infrastructures donc bah cl elles
sont complètement évidemment associé
elles sont également associés dans le
cadre des CLSPD euh qui peuvent al il en
a pas partout mais là où les autorités
ont considéré qu'il était utiile d'en
mettre en place ils ont vocation à
évidemment associer pardon associer les
les les collectivité territoriale sur le
volet des établissements scolaires et
enfin dans dans le cas des état-majors
de sécurité il peut y avoir aussi une
association de l'éducation nationale aux
travaux pe avoir des étatsmajors de
sécurité spécifiques sur le monde
éducatif mais là effectivement ça plus
concerner les les directeurs
départementaux des services d'éducation
nationale que la collectivité
territoriale voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire au niveau des
différentes questions qui ont été posées
je te laisse réponse sur les fichers
peut-être et sur les la déclinaison
police de ces
questions oui pour compléter ce qui a é
indiqué
euh vous indiquez que la plainte a été
déposée donc elle a été prise il y a pas
de su l'anignant vous dit pas tant qu'il
a pas de suivi vous dit qu'il a pas
d'information sur le suivi et c'est pas
nécessairement la même chose mais vous
soulignez un point important ça veut
dire qu'il y a un enjeu d'information
qui peut revenir au service de police au
gendarmerie mais qui peut aussi revenir
à l'autorité judiciaire donc assurément
il y a probablement non pas une zone
grise mais un un un partage
d'information à compléter euh de manière
de manière à être en mesure de rassurer
sur le fait que
euh la plainte a été traitée avec la
célérité nécessaire et a reçu une
réponse quelle qu'elle soit et je
rejoins ce qu'indiquait tout à l'heure
André petillot sur le profil alors j'ai
pas de donné on sera probablement en
mesure de vous en donner mais sur les
auteurs des faits il a évidemment
beaucoup d'auteurs mineurs et donc dès
lors qu'on est sur des faits commis par
des auteurs mineurs qui pour certains
peuvent être des primo auteurs le sujet
de la réponse euh peut évidemment
parfois répondre à à à réponse pénale du
niveau de réponse pénale peut poser la
question de savoir s'il est adapté ou
pas mais assurément il y a un enjeu
àprèant mieux informé sur le sur le
suivi les conventions que je mentionnais
ce sont des conventions de partenariat
éducation nationale intérieure justice
alors j'ai pas les références ici mais
je les r trouvit qui
euh sont pas nécessairement signés dans
la totalité des départements j'ai pas
les données j'ai pas les données
complètes mais qui ont voocation
justement à traiter des signalements qui
sont réalisés au titre de l'article 40
donc l'article 40 c'est le signalement
de la survenance d'une infraction et
l'articulation avec la réponse
judiciaire et la réponse disciplinaire
donc elle vise à cette logique
d'approche pluridisciplinaire et c'est
des outils qui pourraent être
intéressants aussi pour pour contribuer
à l'information des des des victimes est
entendu que nous sommes sur des faits
qui sont en nombre mais qui sont pas à
ce point massif que nous ne sommes pas
en mesure de faire du suivi ind
individuel me me me semble-t-il pardon m
elles ne sont pas systématiques ces
conventions manifestement ell ne le sont
pas je je je compléterai aussi mes
éléments de réponse écrit sur ce sur ce
sujet là j'ai pas de
donné en nombre sur les sur les
départements pour vous indiquer où elles
sont mais en tout cas il en
existe je poursuis sur le sujet
spécifique des fichiers s alors vous
savez que la fiche s euh c'est c'est un
outil c'est un outil qui vise à
permettre le suivi d'une personne qui
peut être dans un domaine judiciaire ou
dans un domaine administratif et qui
couvre des situations extrêmement
variables elles peuvent dans un certain
nombre de situations couvrir des
situations de
radicalisation nous n'avons pas vocation
à indiquer aux établissements scolaires
qui est fichers ou qui ne l'est pas par
contre il existe dans tous les
départements des
cpraf des cellules de prévention de la
radicalisation et d'accompagnement des
familles qui vise notamment à prendre en
compte le cas des mineurs signalés comme
radicalisé ou en voie de radicalisation
et à réunir sous l'autorité du
préfet les acteurs de cette de ce sujet
intégrant évidemment les correspondants
de l'éducation nationale qui sont
membres de ccpraf et si vous regardez
les instructions donné par le
gouvernement sur le le le suivi de de de
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard il a
été é demandé par une instruction une
circulaire conjointe du ministre de
l'intérieur et du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de réunir dans les
meilleures dél la PRF pour traiter des
situations à prendre en compte donc dans
ce type de structure qui sont des
structures restreintes ou des
information protégé peuvent être
partagées on peut évoquer ces situations
et elles ont à cette occasion vocation à
être à être
partagé s'il n'y a plus de questions je
me tourne vers mes collègues mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a plus il nous
reste à vous remercier euh et les autres
des réponses précises que vous nous avez
apporté concernant les les chiffres sur
lequels vous êtes engagés bien sûr on
est très demandeur de les recevoir pour
être le plus précis possible dans notre
analyse de le de de la situation merci
beaucoup